this right here is our derivative
intuition module and it was a module
that was contributed by ben eater and
it's a pretty interesting module one
it's neat and graphical and all the rest
but what's really cool about it is it
really helps to
conceptualize what a derivative is all
about and all it really is is the slope
of the tangent line at any point so in
this in this exercise right over here
they've graphed f of x is equal to 2x to
the third power so this is 2x to the
third power right over here
and what we need to do is move these
orange dots up and down so these orange
dots right now show a line so when i
highlight on that orange dot you see
this line down here became orange and
right now that orange dot is zero
because the slope of this line right
over here is zero but we see that that
line right now is definitely not tangent
or the slope at that point in our curve
two x to the third is definitely not
zero so we need to do
is we need to move this so it becomes
pretty close as close as we can kind of
eyeball it to the slope of the tangent
line and so that looks about
right about there looks about right that
looks pretty close to the slope of the
curve at that point and you can even see
while i do it up here you see d dx of f
of negative two so the derivative at f
is equal to negative two so that's just
saying when the function is equal to
negative 2 what is the derivative there
that's the slope so by putting it all
the way up here i'm saying that the
slope is equal to 24 at that point so
that's my that's a pretty good
approximation just eyeballing it like
that now let's do this point right over
here
so it looks like the slope is decreasing
a little bit but it's still very
positive so this slope looks maybe it's
close to close to around 14 or 15.
and then over here once again our slope
has decreased but still reasonably
positive the slope looks like it's about
5. so our slope is decreasing right over
here the slope does look like it's about
it's about 0 right over here this looks
like an inflection point actually so our
slope is 0 right there and you see it
the derivative at f is 0 is zero which
just means this is this fancy notation
to say that the slope of the tangent
line or you can say the slope of the
curve at that point is zero it's flat
there and you see it it really is flat
and then you go over here and we look at
want to find the derivative at f is at f
of one and so once again it looks like
the slope is the slope is now increasing
the slope is now increasing so this is
interesting up here the slope was very
positive but it was decreasing as we
went here notice it's getting flatter
and flatter then it goes to zero and now
the slope starts increasing again so at
this point we want to make it tangent
and so now notice the slope has gone up
relative to when we were at one so that
looks like the slope right over there
and then we do the slope over there and
if we get pretty close it'll actually
curve it'll actually draw the curve of
the derivative so there you go and so
it's neat about here we didn't find the
derivative at every point in the curve
we found it just at these special points
that we were able to move these orange
dots for but since we got the orange
dots close enough to to the actual
derivatives just by eyeballing it just
try finding trying to find
trying to look at what the slope of this
tangent line is it said okay you've done
it right and it drew the whole slope of
the derivative and what this entire
derivative is saying at any point this
is the slope of the tangent line so even
though we didn't move a dot around at
negative 0.5 if you go right up here
that looks like it's around i don't know
a little this is two and a half so this
would be a little bit over one it looks
like that is that would be the slope of
the tangent line right over there or if
we went all the way to negative
negative what is this 2.25 the slope of
the tangent line looks like it's
approximately approximately 30 right
over there so once you have the curve
you now have the slope of the tangent
line or you have the slope of the curve
at every point that we see over here so
this is just i thought a pretty a pretty
neat exercise